Hello, I'm Andrew Garfield.
And I'm Claire Foy.
And I'm Andy Serkis, the
director of the upcoming film, Breathe.
We're excited to bring you this new trailer.
It's based on an inspiring true story,
and it will be in theatres this October.
We hope you enjoy it.
She's gorgeous.
Sorry! My fault, sorry.
You can't possibly marry him, Diana.
He's practically a stranger.
It's not as if you don't have other options.
The thing is, I just know this is it.
Oh, I've got news.
Oh yeah?
I'm going to have a baby.
Best news I ever had since I've
proposed and you said yeah.
Robin!
I can't breathe.
You inhaled the polio virus from droplets in the air.
The result is you can't breathe for yourself.
You really must leave me to rot now.
We can't have this.
Apparently, I can.
Get me out of here.
No one with your husband's disability exists
outside a hospital anywhere in the world.
I've just had an idea.
It does his breathing for him.
Oh! Amazing! Hooray!
There'll be no stopping you now, oh boy!
What exactly is it you want from me?
Well, we want more of these chairs.
For people like Robin.
No one's ever believed it's possible to live as you do.
This is bloody marvellous.
Well we should show them.
When I first became paralysed, I wanted to die.
But my wife wouldn't let me.
She told me I had to live to see our
son grow up, so I went on living.
Your life is my life.
Why do you keep your disabled imprisoned?
Go back to your patients and set them free.
I've accepted the risk of dying.
I don't want to just survive.
I want to truly live.